it is beauty week here on the show and
it is a good day to have a good hair day
and we did a look back at the history of
hair in this beauty background
[Music]
hair styling has been around long before
the days of blow dryers hair
straighteners shampoo or conditioner in
fact hair has become a form of identity
with entire decades defined by iconic
looks or should we say iconic locks
in the 20s it was all about the bob
popularized by coco chanel and greta
garbow finger waves hit the scene in the
30s followed by victory rolls in the 40s
and we have to mention the flower power
of billie holiday's iconic gardenia
the 50s brought the pompadour and who
can forget twiggy's show's stopping
pixie from the 60s this decade saw icons
like angela davis and diana ross rock
the afro cementing the style as not just
a hairdo but a symbol of black pride
during the civil rights movement
well of course there was also the 70s
where farrah fawcett's feather dew was
all the rage the 80s brought some
totally rad looks from side high ponies
and crimped hair
and then the 90s gave us some of the
sought after looks such as the rachel
the 2000s blessed us with rihanna's
braids and the many cuts of kristen
stewart today she's sporting a short
blonde look but kristen continues to
prove that there's no limit to what she
can pull off no matter what your own
style is one thing's for sure your hair
is your canvas so don't forget to play
okay joining us now is someone who the
wall street journal called the hit maker
of hollywood hairdos his clients include
kristen stewart jennifer garner reese
witherspoon rosario dawson just to name
a few please say hello to a dear
aberjeel
you have no idea the work that i'm doing
with kristen stewart today is so much
due to
so many references that i pull from work
that you did and i think you probably
did your own hair and makeup some of
these times but it just was
i don't know i think beauty is such a
beautiful way to express yourself and
you did it in a beautiful way and in the
90s honestly like it is ethnic um
my dear friend justin long
dated i don't know for many years i
literally would say to him i'd be like
can't you go and get a deer to cut oh my
god
i remember i used to literally he always
looked so handsome after getting his
hair cut with you i love love love that
man he always looked his best after
being in your chair
thank you um well okay before the show
you met one of our viewers julie and she
was thinking hair transformation
here's what she looked like before which
by the way is gorgeous i'm into that oh
yeah oh how awesome is this texture yeah
okay well i can't wait to see what you
did okay um a deer take me through it
let's go and do this
[Applause]
okay
turn around
[Applause]
so
immediately when i saw her i thought all
right let's take off some of this length
let's give you more volume let's give
you a little bit more highlights and
this was really great one of the tips
that i taught you today is when you're
doing a center part follow the bridge of
your nose and that's right where you
have to have your middle parting so
that's super simple and if you're going
to do a side part follow the arch of
your brow so that's where you go and you
put a deep side part right so if i was
gonna change this you guys
look at that
immediately
you end up
you end up getting a really nice lift
i'm going to show you the way that i get
these really beautiful simple waves the
secret is taking your iron right and all
you're going to really want to do is
just create this really easy movement
back and forth
just like that and that's going to give
you that perfect perfect lift in wave so
that's a great tip
and then to really finish the look and
and get rid of a little bit of the frizz
you want to use an oil that isn't too
heavy this is a virtue healing oil it's
really lightweight it's super simple i
use a few drops like that and then never
apply it add the root area only from
your brows down so if you tilt your hair
you just are going to take it and i just
want you to see the difference so as i'm
running it
look at what happens between
this side and that side right so it's a
really nice
it's a really nice beautiful easy trick
again tilt for me
and then you just run it don't put it
near your roots your blowout will last a
very long time and then you just get
this beautiful gorgeous shiny sexy waves
i hope you're gonna try this at home
you are literally the vision and the
creative director and the chemist and
the brains behind virtue yes and virtue
is some of the best products i've ever
used in my life a deer i mean so good
right how do you feel amazing perfect
because thank you everything
oh my god oh yeah thank you and that's
the thing there is no right or wrong
ever there's so honestly there's so many
great tips even when you're blow drying
your hair as an example right and you're
running we're all busy we don't have
time
blow dry only the top of your hair
literally this section do a v-section
blow-dry that let the rest air dry and
your hair will look incredible literally
like maybe like two and a half minutes
it's that simple oh my gosh yeah dear
you are so amazing all right you used
two uh tools the flower hair tools and
the ionic pro dryer and the styling iron
on julie and guess what everyone in the
audience is gonna go home with both
the flower
dryer and the styling iron and now
thanks to you
we know what to do with that
yes
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]